hi there and welcome to this motion
science video my name is cameron and i'm
so glad to have you here with me today
because we are going to talk
about inspiration and where to find
inspiration
when you're feeling a little bit like
you're in a creative rut
and not sure where to
what exploration to explore what
concepts to explore
where to go what to do and we've all
been there
and sometimes we have creative ruts for
quite a while sometimes we don't
sometimes we're on inspiration highs for
a long time but when we do hit
a creative rut uh these are some places
you can check out
and also if you're not in a creative rut
these are also just great
resources to uh just kind of keep your
creative process
going this is what i like to do i don't
just
stick with one way of designing or
animating i like to always kind of be
exploring and see what other people are
doing
out there art has been done a million
and one ways
nothing is original everything has been
done before it's just how you kind of
approach it
and what your take and your style
is on that particular creative approach
so these are three simple sites just for
in general creative inspiration i like
to go to this first one here is behance
and what i love about behance is it
starts to curate a collection of images
for you based on what you've
liked or looked at in the past
based on their algorithm so for example
if i
like i'm immediately drawn to this first
image here and behance is
pretty good at knowing what i'm going to
like so if i click this
and you know i really dig the
inspiration here
a couple things i'm going to do here i'm
probably going to appreciate the project
and that tells behance like hey cameron
really likes this image
let's feed him some more imagery like
this some more art like this
um also what i could do is i could save
it right i can add it to a mood board
and that's what's great about behance is
you can create mood boards here
uh to save collections of images so if i
wanted to say this to a mood board i can
add it to
one of my mood boards already have here
or i could create a new mood board
and you know call it whatever i want to
call it and save it and i'm good to go
great way to keep inspiration all in one
place
uh just to show you i'm gonna go to my
motion science page here
i'm gonna go to my mood board click here
and you can see immediately these are
just some simple mood boards i've set up
maybe when you're watching this video
there's gonna be a lot more here
um i hope to really grow the mood boards
here so
give us a like and a follow not a like
give us a follow here
right come check it out you're gonna get
lots of great inspiration here so
a lot of this imagery here that you're
seeing is what's inside of the
stylecraft course what we pull from
where we really study
what uh is these these different aspects
these different
designs and principles of motion design
so for instance if you go into
atmosphere here
you're going to see different mood
boards here for atmosphere and then you
can click on these
and go even further in and really
explore the quicktime
or the style frames like you see here
great great resource for finding
inspiration
i'm going to go back here to the main
let's go back to 4u
and this is where you're going to see
imagery that behance thinks you're going
to like
it's also great just to search right so
let's let's say i'm looking for
something like retro
you can get very specific or you can
keep it more generalized like maybe
retro 80s
i can click that it's going to load up
retro 80s
boards here that things i might like or
retro 80 projects i should say not
boards
there's lots of great stuff to look at
here i could also narrow this down into
a creative field like i could go
directly into motion graphics if i
wanted to and these are all going to be
most likely animated pieces or style
frames
from retro 80s type projects
one thing i do like to do when i'm
searching for inspiration
a lot of times i'm not going to click
motion graphics i'm going to keep it on
all
creative fields for the most part
because i find that a lot of inspiration
comes from
uh areas outside of motion graphics
right there's
there's art there's graphic design
there's
paintings there's architecture there's
magazines magazines are highly
inspirational to me at this point
um i mean look at this right here this
is really cool stuff here
what is it looks like it's it's posters
so i was immediately drawn to it right i
love
a lot about this image i love the
texture the colors the use of typography
these are all ways that i'm going to get
inspired to create like a retro 80s
project it's something i just recently
worked on
and uh you know i found a lot of
inspiration here on
behance for that same with like
typography sometimes you can go into
typography and you can find actually
find like downloads
uh for different typefaces uh within
these projects this one doesn't have a
typeface but
uh i'm sure it's probably not too hard
to find one
here we go thunderstorm typeface i'll
click on that sometimes they're free
sometimes you have to pay
for commercial licenses but i can see it
you know how it's being used here
really cool stuff typically i can scroll
way down here
and get struck here that's the name of
the typeface
i can download it there or um check out
another awesome retro font right here on
behance
so again you can go down a rabbit hole
here i do advise you to
save these to mood boards and really
kind of
keep things organized and and so you
know where to look like you know i would
maybe say this stuff as
retro 80s typefaces or maybe just
typefaces in general
i don't know it just depends how you
want to work next
site i like to use looking for
inspiration it's the big one is
pinterest
if you do do not follow motion science
on pinterest please do
you can see we have a few followers here
we get a lot of people coming here
every month to check out what we post
and what we save into boards a lot of
this stuff
we're constantly adding to it right so
you can see there's a lot of actually
locked boards here and these are boards
that we use
for projects that are up and coming that
we're
getting inspired from and maybe we're
just not ready to to show this to the
world yet
but there's tons and tons and tons of
boards here
that are not locked so for example
motion science board you can click on
this
you can come in and you can see
different workshops that we have here at
motion science
like we see here so this is all the
different workshops we have
in our pro flows program or our
membership
if we go back let's say again you look
for 80s inspiration
the 80s come in here find some imagery
that inspires you
uh for example let's say we may be like
this and what's great about pinterest is
it's going to give us more options
more boards that it thinks we might like
and you can go down a rabbit hole here
of finding a different inspiration that
you really dig
and then what you can do it's the same
thing you can add it to the 80s board
but just clicking save
or i could even actually i like this one
a lot let's go ahead and save that to
the 80s
if we find one that maybe like this one
and we want to save it to a completely
new board we can create a board or we
can scroll through our boards to find
the appropriate board
that this image should be added to and
save it there
so the only reason there's so many
different types of boards here is
because
when i'm looking for something very
specific for inspiration
you know i want to know exactly where i
need to go to find that inspiration
so that's why there's so many boards
here so let's go back out here to the
main
uh profile and let's say
you know like i need to work on a
project for
um oh i don't know something that's like
kind of grungy
right so grunge i absolutely love grunge
i've got different boards here
for grunge uh if i can find something
like broken
like even boards that aren't necessarily
titled grunge i know that they have
specific
imagery within them that might inspire
me as well
so let's go up here let's find
one nin concert visuals a lot of grunge
in there
uh looking through here
dark thriller this is a good one here so
these are all like
movie posters uh but they're obviously
very dark
but they have like some grunge elements
to them like look at this one here just
it's very dark and moody and grungy with
that texture of the top so this is going
to inspire me
and what i like to do is also just kind
of pull different
assets different pieces of
boards that i find inspirational so
let's say for instance on this seven
frame here maybe i just like the way
that the word seven is written out or
maybe i like the whole
block of type here so i'm gonna save
that as inspiration
for the type but maybe
um i really like the
imagery here the way the imagery is used
with a negative space
right that's a really great use of
negative space here and contrast so
maybe that's part of the imagery
uh maybe i'm going to i'm needing some
help i've got some different textures
and things like that i like
uh but i also need to oh let's say we
need to add in
some depth so maybe i'll come into my
depth board here and find some
some ideas for depth in here or
maybe i need to focus on color
i've got a color board here it's very
broad uh it's got quite a few pins in it
and there's just lots of different
references to color in here well
actually i clicked on typography by
accident but
again you can see lots of different
typography
references here right so a lot of
inspiration can come from this from just
looking at these different frames
maybe clicking on one and if that's not
completely the way i need to go
i can still find other ideas here to
continue my search on so pinterest
is where it's at for a ton of
inspiration go give motion science a
follow
i promise you won't be disappointed
lastly
a great place for inspiration is
actually on instagram
and i hear a lot of people give
instagram a lot of flack
you know a lot of the artwork on
instagram maybe looks the same but it
all depends on who you
follow so for instance the french monkey
this guy
is a awesome awesome 3d
creator i would say he works a lot in um
3d modeling and just creating some
really trippy visuals that just always
look beautiful
so i like to scroll through instagram
and just get inspiration from instagram
cult class this is a woman who does um
montage designs uh with
you know all different types of assets a
lot of retro
photography sometimes with like alien
ships like you see here
but really fun stuff very inspirational
right even if i look at this and just
get inspired by the color palette up in
here i really like that a lot
uh scroll down here's another great
artist
glabool
really cool stuff motionographer pro
great great stuff there cult class again
more ufo ships
and uh steucer is how i pronounce it
i'm sure a lot of you guys follow this
guy great 3d artist as well
this is this guy right here is um is
amazing
for his um use of
parallax
right now this particular example isn't
uh so much about parallax i guess
but if i go into uh his content here
you're gonna see uh some of the stuff
this guy's done
i mean like that you know that's a
photograph that he animated and brought
to life through
parallax and some things like that so
really cool
work uh again you when you follow
people on instagram you want to follow
people who really
inspire you don't just follow what's
trending
right look for people who inspire you
blackbook studio these guys don't post
very often but when they do
i find their work highly inspirational
they do a lot of
type for um film and tv
uh this guy i think it's strictly mostly
on the graphic design side of things but
i really like
the artwork you don't have to always
follow just people who do
motion pieces uh ashworth chris chris
asworth um amazing grungy
design but anyways what i like to do
here is i will scroll through instagram
typically on my phone and if i find an
image that really inspires me
i will either take a screenshot and save
that image or i'll take a screen
recording if it's in motion
and watch that recording and then i will
save the screenshot or the screen
recording
into a folder structure in my photos
so i use an iphone it's really easy to
set up a folder structure within photos
and i'll call it like instagram you know
inspiration
if i get real specific if i'm working on
a particular project it might be like
again 80s retro and i'll drop it into
that folder
and i know that i can always go into
that folder and pull up the inspiration
for what i like you can also save here
forward it to someone for maybe
inspiration for them
but again this is a great way to find
inspiration another easy way on
instagram is just to search
hashtags so if i look for something like
motion design
um i guess you can't do it here on the
computer but you can search uh
hashtags on instagram on your phone
and it's an easy way to look for
inspiration again don't just stick with
motion
terms search things like like grunge
like we're talking about grunge or 80s
or retro
anything like that that's going to give
you more inspiration more ways to look
uh for more inspiration to to inspire
you to be creative
so that my friends is three places where
you can go to find inspiration i use
them every single week
probably every single day to get
inspiration and i'm
constantly saving imagery to a board or
to
a folder location for future reference
because you want to have all these
assets
someplace where you can just easily pull
from and get inspired
immediately so hopefully you learned
something uh good today
and maybe you've got three new places to
check out for
inspiration until next time my name is
cameron
and this is motion science
you